monopolies and misinformation on social
media will be a part of the focus
of an unprecedented hearing on capitol
hill today
the heads of amazon apple facebook and
alphabet which owns google
will participate remotely they're among
the richest people on the planet
the house judiciary committee is
investigating whether their companies
have too much power
errol barnett joins us from outside
google's headquarters in new york errol
what can we expect
good morning jericho i think figurative
fireworks are within the realm of
possibility here these house members
will really be grilling these titans of
tech on whether their companies wield
too much influence and under that they
will discuss the spread of
misinformation online during
this ongoing pandemic on sites like
facebook
in fact facebook ceo mark zuckerberg is
expected to admit
during his opening statement that his
company has a quote responsibility to
stop bad actors
and he will say that facebook is taking
aggressive steps to stop covert 19
related
misinformation from spreading but we've
all seen
or at least know about that video
purporting to be of doctors
saying things about the virus that are
not true it was amplified by president
trump and seen more than 14 million
times before facebook took it down
yesterday i spoke with the chairman of
this committee that's representative
david cicilline
about whether he believes facebook is
doing enough
i think what people will learn is some
of the most engaging most
profitable things that are posted on
facebook are the things that are not
true that
track conspiracy theories or crazy other
claims and facebook i think has not done
enough
to prevent that from happening in fact
is profiting from it
this will also be the first
congressional testimony from the world's
richest man that's amazon ceo jeff bezos
and in his opening statement he is
expected to defend
his company's dominance in the retail
space he's expected to say his company
can have both
the scope and capabilities of a large
company while maintaining the heart and
the spirit of a small
one anthony we'll see if folks there on
capitol hill
will be buying that should be an
interesting hearing errol thank you